this is pyro for a creation that can
visualize sound waves with fire and this
is what music looks like at last someone
has invented that disco barbecue this
was one of the most awesome music
visualizers I've ever seen have probably
also the most dangerous
yes mixing fire with flammable gas is
dangerous but how can they show sound
waves with flames this pirate box is
made of a metal box with evenly spaced
holes a fuel source in this case propane
and a speaker attached to the side of
the box when they play a single tone
through the speaker this creates a sound
wave which travels through the gas
creating areas of high and low pressure
above an area of high pressure a lot of
gas will come out of those holes above
an area of low pressure it would be less
gas and that's why you get different
sized flames in different parts of the
box but it gets more complicated than
this because the wave can be reflected
off the edge of the box where two areas
of high pressure from different waves
meet they can interfere with each other
creating an even higher pressure and
therefore an even bigger flame
I love it when they just throw in some
banging music you can't analyze that
instead just stand back and watch the
slants dance four and five